انا في موسكو
واسافر
عبر المنطقه وحتى في منطقه مختلفه من
روسيا فلنستطيع ان
نرى لو كان هنالك اثر على الاقتصاد فلا
يلاحظ مثلا بعض محاله التسوق الكبيره او
المحلات الغربيه اغلقت والتي اغلقت لفتره
والبعض عده افتتاحها باسماء مختلفه ولكن
لا يوجد اي احساس بالانخفاض او الانحدار
الاقتصادي لا احد يتحدث عن خساره الوظائف
او انخفاض في الدخل في الحقيقه لمن يعيش
في موسكو الان
ولم يقرا الاخبار العالميه فما كان ليعرف
ان هنالك نزاع اصلا فلم يتغير الكثير
للحياه اليوميه للشعب الروسي
فيما يخص الظروف المعيشيه وامكانيه حصولهم
على الدعم الاجتماعي والوظائف وغيرها لم
يتغير الكثير على الارض
خلال العام الماضي
ولكن بلا شك نحن ندخل مرحله تحوليا حيث
العقوبات باتت اشد الان وبالتالي فان
الموقف في عام 23 بلا شك سيكون
او لا يصب كثيرا في مصلحه روسيا او اصعب
على اقتصاد الروسي ما كان عليه في عام
2022 لذلك اعتقد بان هذا العام اثر
العقوبات بلا شك سيكون اكثر وضوحا